sieht man käse gegessen freunde herzlich
willkommen zu diesem video ich weiß
nicht was mich erwartet und das ist auch
der sinn vom heutigen video denn die ich
habe entdeckt dass es in der chefkoch
app-geschäft glaube ich jeder größte sap
portal in deutschland ich habe entdeckt
dass es dort einen knopf für zufällige
rezepte gibt und was soll ich sagen ich
wehre mich wenn ich nicht einen tag lang
diesen knopf drücken ich weiß nicht ob
es eine gute idee ist aber ich werde
diesen knopf vier heute drei mal drücken
und es kann halt alles sein ihr seht da
oben filet wellington städte das ist ein
lieblings hin zum frühstück machen ich
werde wirklich probieren alles was
ansatzweise machbar ist umzusetzen das
ist also soweit wir klicken jetzt den
knopf zufälliges rezepte etwas was nicht
so lange dauert heute ich hab todes
hunger ihr setzt zuerst
pflaumenkuchen mit streuseln arbeitszeit
15 minuten insgesamt eine stunde fünf
leute also eine stunde schmeckt mir
wirklich überhaupt nicht aber
ich habe auch sonst keine option also
ich muss das ding jetzt machen wir
gucken mal was wir brauchen 550 gramm
butter zucker eigelb vanille zucker mehl
das ist alles alles was man dafür
braucht wahrscheinlich macht man aus
einem teig dem boden aber auch die
streusel drei viertel der film ist eine
mischung geben und zum teig wurden genau
hat der fluggast direkt richtig geraten
ja was soll ich sagen halt ein einer
stunde essen dann ist eigentlich auch
schon fast nachmittag aber machen wir
das jetzt also wir kaufen jetzt ein und
wir sehen uns bereichern alles da ist so
leute hier sind auch die einkäufe
relativ überschaubar mehl zucker eigelb
laumen vanille zucker und butter
wirklich eigentlich eine einfache nummer
und wenn ich auch mal so darüber
nachdenke jetzt beim einkaufen ist mir
aufgefallen so ein stück pflaumenkuchen
zum frühstück ist eigentlich nichts
worüber man sich beschweren kann deshalb
lasst uns mal gemeinsam in das rezept
gucken wo mit fangen wir an die butter
gemeinsam mit der zucker in einem topf
erhitzen bis sie geschmolzen ist
mehrfach gut umrühren und etwas abkühlen
lassen es gab nicht auf allzu hoher
stufe butter rein das erst mal die
butter ein bisschen an schmelzen damit
nicht der zucker dann irgendwie auf dem
topf boden liegt aber ihr seht das geht
relativ flott eigelb und mehl in eine
rührschüssel geben kurs mit demnächst
gerät umrühren ich habe ich hier eine
rührschüssel vorbereitet jeweils erst
ist das mail hinein sagt darauf hin dass
13 stück sind das insgesamt ich habe
mich schon eingeschlagen und getrennt
alles rein die butter schmilzt ist auch
wirklich ne ganze ecke butter also 150
gramm und jetzt kommt der zucker drauf
dann würden wir dann mit 1 ist auf jeden
fall schillig ist konzept für meine
verhältnisse auch weil mein persönlicher
koch vor allem ist es häufig ein
bisschen fordern dass sowas hier ich
will mich überhaupt nicht beschweren im
gegenteil
der hase ist eingesteckt und jetzt das
ganze vorsichtig verspüren dass alles
gut unter gemeint ist das hat wirklich
unfassbar eintracht
muss ich ja ich habe das noch nie
gemacht so einem flaum streuselkuchen
meine oma hat es unendliche male gemacht
und ich habe schon etliche male gegessen
das wird glaube ich eine leckere sache
dann schauen wir jetzt mal weiter eigelb
und mehrere schlüssel mit butter zucker
masse hinzugeben und mit dem mix gerät
nur so lange rühren bis 1 krümelige teig
entstanden drei viertel in eine
springform und also dann die pflaumen
drauf das heißt sie müssen die flammen
erst mal vorbereiten indem wir sie
entkernen also pflaume einmal halbieren
da nehmen wir den finger und ziehen das
einmal raus gerne zur seite nächster
schritt die masse jetzt unter rühren
heißt das hier dreht sich einmal schön
und wir dürfen das langsam nur bis sich
grobe krümel wählen bei dem ölstaat
kommt mir schon an seine grenzen aber
das sieht schöner dann brauchen wir
einen backpapier zuschnitt nehmen unsere
form machen die springform auf
packpapier frauen wieder drauf zu machen
den ganzen hasen und nehmen drei viertel
von unserer menge heraus jetzt soll man
das ganze mit einem löffel andrücken so
schön verstreichen ist ein gültiger
versuch auf jeden fall wir führten die
flammen noch einmal schnell gehen sie
dann auch schon auf zu boden wir machen
das jetzt extra so ein bisschen hübsch
in die mitte ausgerichtet ok kleinigkeit
habe ich hier wohl übersehen ist mir
gerade aufgefallen aber das gar nicht
schlimm dem strich jetzt drüber der
karamellisiert an nämlich nochmal schön
und gibt ein schönes vanille aroma ja
und jetzt kommen halt gestreute darüber
ist wo immer ein
probieren das ganze auch noch das ist
einfach so hey leute ich kann nichts
anderes sagen außer dass ich echt stolz
genau das gilt was sich das zeigt also
schnappen wir uns den ganzen ab in den
backofen
45 minuten ist leicht es ist soweit
lasst uns frühstücken wir wollen den
kuchen raus und wie sieht er aus
das sieht nicht schlecht aus wir packen
wir mal hier drauf ist schön offenbach
ist schon ein bisschen ausgekühlt und
wir nehmen etwa die strafbank machen sie
auch so
schnell dass man direkt ein schönes
saftiges stück aus der mitte heraus und
nicht zu klein welche wirklich hunger
und
der ist das gute stück die rolle
[Musik]
so leute das war wirklich glück wenn ich
jetzt darüber nachdenken und davor stehe
das war wirklich einfach glück dass ich
das bekommen habe ich kenne märz ein
stück kann mir gut vorstellen dass der
leser übrig da hinten auch lust hat aber
ich finde als erstes dran ich mache
vorkoster quasi einmal für uns vor
dass dennoch so wahn ist das ist so
krass irgendwie säure ist da wir würden
10.000 sachen einfallen die man dazu
noch machen könnte und so leute wenn ihr
darauf mal lust habe dass wir ein
zufälliges gericht nehmen und darf so
krass machen vision geht dann sagt auf
jeden fall bescheid aber ich esse stück
und zeigt euch da mal was und zwar wie
unfassbar weil ich diese flammen
geworden sind okay du die auch ein stück
und wir sehen uns zum mittagessen zeit
fürs mittagessen leute wir haben fast 15
uhr ich bin schon wieder komplett
hungrig und hoffe dass es irgendetwas
gibt was schnell geht was vor allem
lecker ist ich meine ich habe selbst
schon mal ein video gemacht was für
abgründe gibt auf chefkoch.de und falls
irgendetwas davon kommt wäre nicht so
schön also tun wir es und klicken auf
zufälliges rezept
asiatische rindfleisch pizza bin mir
nicht sicher welcher gourmet da am werk
war aber vielleicht schmeckt ja wer weiß
dauert nur 15 minuten worüber ich sehr
zufrieden bin und wir gucken auf die
zutaten einen pizzateig selbst gemacht
steht hier schaffen wir wirklich nicht
leute bis wir den selbst gemacht haben
der muss ja dann auch noch gehen und so
weiter und so fort wir kaufen einen
verein die zutaten kriege ich alle aber
gucken wir mal das bild an 4,6 sterne
sehe ich auf jeden fall 4,6 sterne sind
da und ich komme gleich wieder vom
einkaufen und dann geht's los wenn ich
die zutaten hier sehe sieht das ganze
gar nicht mehr so schlecht aus irgendwie
habe ich richtig bock drauf so eine
leicht exotische pizza auch wenn
wahrscheinlich jeder italiener wieder
sagt ey du alles auf eine pizza außer
häuschen so ist chili sauce wir fangen
an und schneiden zuallererst unseren
einzelnen champagner aus so steht
nämlich im ritz fdp zehn scheiben
schneiden ein drittel der chilli in
ringe schneiden den rest hatten das
rindfleisch in streifen schneiden es
wirklich nicht allzu dick nicht zu dünn
du wirst bescheid dann nehmen wir die
schote weil wir keine weicheier sind
machen wir das ganze mit kern so gehabt
dann schaffen wir uns hier ein bisschen
platz wir schärfen unser messer noch mal
zu mir ist richtig schöne streifen zu
schneiden
das fleisch ist soweit und das herr beer
ich jetzt noch mal wir wollen keine so
super langen stücke haben sondern so ein
bisschen so wir gehen jetzt ein bisschen
erdnussöl in die familie hinein und
darin braten wird so wie es im rezept
steht unsere rindfleisch greifen an
dabei sollen wir sie mit pfeffer und
salz würzen ist schon relativ edel
eigentlich wenn man so darüber nachdenkt
weil das rindfleisch dass er jetzt drin
ist kostet auch schnell 10 euro 8 euro
also ist natürlich kein schlechtes und
dann wird schon schnelle edel kids hier
dass wir vorbereiten gucken wir mal wie
es weitergehen in pizza teig auf einer
bemehlten fläche dünn ausrollen
ok erstmal hier weitermachen wir uns
jetzt direkt schon runter auch wenn es
noch relativ hohe ist teilweise aber es
gibt glaube ich wirklich nur uns
anbraten weil sonst wird der komplette
hard im ofen deshalb machen wir das mal
so jedoch gar nicht mal so schlecht aus
wir machen das mal auf ich weiß gar
nicht was mich hier erwartet
oh
mein gott wird verdacht das ist so
outlook nichtig so wäre jetzt unseren
pizzateig hier auf der arbeitsfläche
verteilt und werden ihnen dünn ausrollen
allerdings nicht rund sondern passend zu
unserem pizza stein quadratisch
rechteckig jetzt gucken wir mal nach was
wir als nächstes brauchen häuschen soße
und sweet chili sauce mischen und zwar
stimmt das ist mir pizza ohne tomaten um
mein gott drei esslöffel sweet chili und
ein halber esslöffel häuschen er jetzt
wird es wirklich perrys eltern wenn man
so viel
war noch dazu das ist vermischen wir ein
bisschen nächster schritt mozzarella und
davon drei viertel darauf verteilen die
zwei geriebener mozzarella aber wir
haben uns diesen hier
jetzt müssen wir noch paprika zwiebeln
lauch zwiebeln schneiden pizza belegen
das ganze machen wir jetzt in tirol und
dann sehen wir uns gleich werden
gegessen wird
[Musik]
wir brauchen jetzt ein scharfes messer
und brad grüße gehen raus und gehen
jetzt mal ein wenig koriander oben auf
unsere pizza koriander mag nicht jeder
und ich mögen deshalb sehr gut und dann
hätte ich natürlich trotzdem essen
müssen bisschen frisch gezuckt einfach
ansonsten bleibt es eigentlich fast
nicht mehr viel übrig außer in der mitte
durchzuschneiden jetzt leute ein stück
von dieser sogenannten pizza mit gucken
einfach mal drauf und rico champignons
paprika
chili koriander alles auf einem und
nicht zu vergessen sweet chili sauce
klappen die pizza von unten dreht sie
echt gar nicht mal falsch aus aber ist
nicht super knusprig und jetzt bin ich
sehr gespannt ob sich die arbeit gelohnt
hat und
hunger davon gestellt wird
das ist das noch pizza habe ich das noch
pizza ist überhaupt aber schmeckt keine
falsch täglich oder so es hat halt
wirklich nur wenig mit pizza zu tun
dadurch dass keine tomate da ist wo man
eher direkt von seiner süßliche note
gehütet wird durch die sweet chili sauce
zum beispiel ist das wirklich ein sehr
irritieren das erlebnis ich weiß auch
nicht wie ich besser beschreiben kann
ich gleich noch mal was soll ich sagen
es schmeckt eigentlich ganz gut man wird
sagt auch geht fällt das ist das
wichtigste das werde ich nämlich jetzt
auch satt und dann sehen wir uns zum
abendessen wieder so freunde hat es mich
glücklich gemacht das mittagessen nicht
wirklich wir schauen jetzt was das
abendessen wird
nicht nicht wahr davon hätte ich doch
nichts sagt glasierten möhren gemüse
einfach nur möhren decker 12 möhren
gemüse vor butter zucker petersilie das
muss ich jetzt neben oder was er
wirklich merkst du ich bin wirklich so
ich bin echt traurig drüber aber scheiß
doch wir machen das dann gesundes
abendessen heute ich kaufe ein und dann
gibt's glasiert es mir und gemüse
mehreren petersilie gemüse von butter
pfeffer meine abendessen nehmen was soll
ich sagen leute ist auf jeden fall ein
kohlenhydrat armes abendessen dass wir
heute vor uns haben und ich guck mal wie
wir hier anfangen zunächst ein
zentimeter grünen der möhren stehen
lassen so wie hier und den rest
abschneiden habe mir schon gemacht die
möhren schälen und unten an der spitze
circa 1 cm abschneiden let's go also
unten etwa ein zentimeter ab und dann
schälen wir das ganze auch schon immer
schön vom körper weg so das mache ich
jetzt mit allen höhen und dann sehen wir
wie es weitergeht so alles vorbereitet
wir haben die möhren jetzt geschält und
tatsächlich ließ im rezept dann auch
noch das schwarz oben weitestgehend
entfernt so 20 gramm butter in eine
beschichtete pfanne zerlassen den zucker
darin schmelzen und leicht
karamellisieren
ich kriege irgendwie flashbacks an heute
morgen also jetzt ein esslöffel zucker
in butter das ist irgendwie so eine
never-ending-story heute ich bin auch
froh wenn ich morgen einfach wieder
essen kann worauf ich lust habe aber
nichtsdestotrotz wobei der geschichte
heute mittag auch wenn ich super lecker
fand fast schon mal cool so etwas neues
auszuprobieren und heute morgen war
einfach ein voller also das heißt zwar
ein bisschen länger gedauert und so
weiter und so fort aber ich will mich
überhaupt nicht beschweren weil das
frühstück dieser kuchen immer noch da
hinten stehen zwar echt lecker und ich
konnte auf den rest noch zu essen es
wird leicht braun jetzt hier und beginnt
zusammen zu spielen also die
kanalisation finde statt und jetzt wo
das geregelt ist bisschen runter mit der
hitze und rein mit den möhren new york
nehmen wir direkt im zweiten fall länder
zur hilfe damit ihr auch gleichmäßig
berührt werden von der gurten ist und
ich werden den gemüse- und angießen und
ist auch wenig flüssigkeit zehn minuten
reduzieren jetzt kommt
ja jetzt bleibt uns gar nicht viel übrig
als ganz so hoch drehen und 10 minuten
köcheln lassen also ihr seht schon
nichts mehr übrig von der gemüsebrühe
ganze ist auch schon deutlich weicher
geworden und jetzt gehen ein bisschen
rund dann mit der temperatur geben
unsere restliche butter dazu sagt und
glasieren das ganze darin jetzt noch mal
schön sieht ehrlich lecker aus also ich
muss sagen das könnte glaube ich preis
werden also ist er so eine vorspeise und
nicht ein gesamtes abendessen aber was
soll's zusammen können und sehr fein
schneiden zum schluss die feinste
geschnittene petersilie unter fügen das
machen wir jetzt noch und dann ist auch
unser abendessen fertig
also wir probieren den ganzen spaß jetzt
mal ich nehme hier mal eine spitze
besonders fein glaube ich ziehe das
nochmal durch die butter und durch die
kräuter auf dem schneidebrett ist
bestimmt heiß noch kommst du so nah dran
und ich probiere
mal süß wie viel ein esslöffel zucker
also der bärenanteil des zuckers kommt
garantiert von den mauren selbst aber
ich muss sagen für das so wenige zutaten
drin sind ist das echt gefährlich werde
es noch meine möhren auf essen dann geht
auch dieser etwas verrückte tag zu ende
ich freue mich wenn ich morgen wieder
nach meinen eigenen wünschen essen kann
aber das war eine positive überraschung
das frühstück auch das mittagessen war
einfach da und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten video